days of overstuffed wallets in your back
pocket or purse might soon come to an
end by 2020 mobile wallets on our
smartphones are expected to surpass the
use of credit and debt debit cards in
the u.s. that has already happened in
China Ben Tracy is in Beijing to show us
what a nearly cashless society actually
looks like Ben good morning good morning
so when I moved here to China a couple
of months ago I kept getting funny looks
every time I would pull cash out of my
wallet to pay for things and then I got
one of these it's a code on my phone and
now I can basically buy anything here in
China when you pay for something how do
you pay for it well that's fun on the
streets of Beijing cash is definitely
not king what do you think of people who
use cash to pay for things you've yes
all day that's rare and weird he says
only the elderly and people who don't
know how to use a phone pay cash this
woman says I rarely take my wallet when
I go out just my phone that's because
those phones can buy just about anything
from clothes in the store to steamed
buns on the street they're used to pay
for bike rides and bus rides rent and
utility bills when was the last time you
used cash WeChat in a leap a dominate
China's mobile market and payments on
their platforms totaled more than five
point five trillion dollars last year a
200% jump from the year before and
nearly 50 times more than the value of
mobile payments in the u.s. one of the
big reasons mobile payments have caught
on so quickly here in China is because
of what most people here don't have in
their wallets credit cards they
basically went from a cash based society
to a cashless one and skipped the step
in between China has leapfrogged the
u.s. into going to a cashless society
Andy Mok is an economist in Beijing he
says China's cashless revolution has
happened in just three years largely
thanks to these things called QR codes
you simply scan them with your phone to
pay nearly every business and person has
one
from the farmers market to the musician
on the street playing for a mobile tip
you can give a homeless person money
with your phone you would never see that
in the US all you have to do scan that
code to transfer money and it really is
ubiquitous in China from the largest
cities the fanciest hotels to the most
humble Street side shacks will all use
QR codes the Chinese are comfortable
doing everything on their phones while
in the u.s. credit cards and online
shopping via personal computers still
rule these kinds of legacy technologies
make any adoption of newer generations
the technologies much more slower so in
this sense I think the US has a little
bit of catching up to do a recent survey
found that 40% of Chinese people carry
less than $15 on them but they would
never dream of leaving home without this
as one guy told me on the street you
can't achieve anything without your
phone that guy on the street was very
correct thank you Ben Tracy didn't you
love how he opened the piece when I
moved to China a couple months ago that
sounded so cool Thank You Ben Tracy
reporting from Beijing